[Music]
it's been 20 years since Carrie Bradshaw
first strut her stuff around New York
City in a tutu excuse me now we're
breaking down seven fashion trends Sex
in the City made fabulous this is all
very informative starting with that gold
nameplate necklace oh say her name to me
don't you dare say her name to me of all
the heartbreaks
in six seasons arguably none were worse
than when Carrie lost her beloved
necklace in Paris no I can't applause my
Carrie was no the dainty acessory made
its debut in season two and popped up
all throughout the series making it a
wardrobe staple and a must-have trend
look I got one just like yours oh wow
that's great then there was the newsboy
cap which Carrie mixed in with her
over-the-top ensembles giving fans
Newsies chic inspo don't say that I know
what's true but don't say it Carrie's
oversized flower pins
became an overnight hit with fans you
can't imagine how flattered I am and
were featured over and over again in
almost every size and color and no one
rocked a crop top like Sarah Jessica
Parker's famous character oh thanks
whether slipping into a sleek
long-sleeved crop to seduce Aidan or
buttoning into a tied-up flannel to bake
him a pie her daring six-pack flaunting
ensembles cinched the deal with viewers
then there were those wild mixed prints
some of her choices may have had you
asking WTF don't do that don't mark the
close but Sex in the City taught fans
anything goes as long as you rock it
with confidence ladies I am having an
epiphany even dresses over jeans a lot
Kerry Slade and fans recreated in masses
and what would carry be without her
killer shoes there's a closet where did
the shoes go specifically her Manolo
Blahniks Mary Jane's
fifties were an urban Schumann the HBO
show made Blahnik a household name and
I'm registered at Manolo Blahnik and
even with their hefty price tag
you know how much manila's aren't women
all over the world were swooning for
Manolo I spent $40,000 on shoes and I
have no place to live I will literally
be the old woman who lived in her shoes
[Music]